are you not like i don't know because i
guess you know you had that like voice
acting experience right so i guess like
the whole like you know
using your voice and being loud and all
that is just like kind of ingrained into
you almost
i just saved that [ __ ] what do you mean
oh really that's optional
uh yeah but it's i think it's more just
a personality personality trait
yeah and on top of that i'm a younger
sibling so i had to do something to get
some damn attention
look at me frankly so
where am i in this story yes so okay so
i was a
casual crossdresser and then when i
moved to hong kong i started
crossdressing in the same capacity so
just going out to rock and roll shows
and things in a dress
right because hong kong's such a
conservative society yep that
yo if i lifted the energy in australia
in hong kong i really really
yeah yeah i would walk in it was just ah
people just lost their minds you're like
the funniest person i've ever seen in my
life
they went bonkers for it so i'm like
damn
so so there we are and we're um you know
figuring out characters for the first
wrestling match
every other wrestler every other
wrestler in hong kong their gimmick was
i am a wrestler right right right so
i'm like like nothing interesting yeah
exactly yeah he's a wrestler
yeah is that all yes okay
so i'm like um what are you good at no
wrestle what is your name
wrestler the wrestler
um so i'm like i'm gonna uh wear a dress
and i'm gonna be called ladybeard
right so all the other wrestlers were
like uh
okay and they were weird about it right
right
first match i go in there overnight most
popular restaurant in hong kong
damn because i was the only one who had
a character try everyone else was a
wrestler the same as the other 20
wrestlers they just seen come out for
him
so what i wanted to know how it's like i
assume this is like the amateur
wrestling scene how do they
how do they introduce new wrestlers um
what's the process for that well uh
okay so like i say you go through you
you do it
a try out and then agree to train you
you start training okay and then when
you get when you're kind of released
publicly as in when you're debuted yeah
uh they'll find a way to debut you so
normally you do it with something public
like a wrestling show
or like a video segment or something
like that yeah and um they'll just
like whoever you are in the ring and
however you're gonna fit into the
company and the stories and so forth
they'll just find a way that works to
introduce your character so let's say
for instance right now
let's say we've been training gantt and
uh for the past
year and gantt's now a skilled young pro
wrestler as you can see
you can see god's been smacking at the
gym on a daily basis
so um okay so what's what's let's make a
gimmick for you real quick
you are the um the you're the the thai
elephant god
sorry okay here's the title of god and
we've decided and currently
uh joey who is the um uh
slightly colorful head luchador
okay he's in a feud with a connor
um uh the welsh despair sorry okay
you
like what the [ __ ] what would you like
to be
anything else would be fine really other
than what's your gimmick
i have interesting colored hair
cool thanks standard of hong kong yeah
that didn't even have interesting color
yeah sorry
that sounded
anyway okay so let's say you guys are
feuding um we'll find
some kind of angle in which during your
story uh for some reason the
thai elephant god is paying huge homage
to the uh multi-colored uh luchador yeah
right and to that end
when you guys are in a match joey will
hit his finisher
and he'll like cover conor it'll be one
two and then the lights will go off and
they'll
come on and riding down the ramp on an
elephant
is the thai elephant god right so let
everybody know that the match is not
gonna end like this right right
or just any damn way you wanna do it
this is one of the beautiful things
about wrestling there's a lot of
potential for creativity and so forth so
so did you get to like say
for instance like the entry right like i
think from what i've heard like each
wrestler
they do they get to choose what song
they enter with
uh yeah it work depends on your company
really right right right but like you
but like
basically the wrestling like every other
time like they get to choose how they
want to enter
i i personally got to but of course
you're limited by
you know what you're capable of doing
copyright i imagine
yeah that can be a problem if it's uh
well yeah it can't be a problem but it's
kind of like
if you're small time you're off into too
small right yeah big time they've got
the rights cleared so
so what's what's like say like for you
for example like what's like your
pinnacle of entries that you remember
because i've seen some because recently
aki has been getting into wwe oh okay
which is
like slightly worrying as well because
i'm like is she gonna be a wwe
girlfriend i don't know about that
but she's but she was watching we were
watching uh like i think it was like the
top 10 like wwe
like most memorable wwe entries and the
one that [ __ ] killed me was one that
john cena did
where he literally somehow got
a hundred john cena lookalikes to come
out in this like
like just this [ __ ] row of people and
they would part ways and
create this like aisle it's the most
accurate thing
the pathways and create this aisle and
then the moment the fireworks went off
they all turned to each other and
started doing this
the real john cena comes and he just
runs through them
fantastic fantastic did you ever get to
do something like that or
uh uh let me tell you something joey the
budget that's been dedicated is
not the same as what dedicated to john
cena okay well then what
what would you say is like yeah this is
like the peak of my entry
of of like a ring of like a ring
entrance i don't know i don't think i've
done anything particularly special as a
ring entrance you don't really like
um off the top of my head
no i don't think i've ever done anything
you just you just kind of show up
get announced you know come out get big
light on you yeah
go around high-fiving the audience yeah
into ring but you to remember when i
come out i've got pigtails in a pink and
white bikini so
just that is somewhat a statement sure
true i don't need to do this joey
everyone's looking already i want them
to see me
all right so you did only terrible only
terrible wwe jokes